[Music]
hey Jake we just got back from playing
three hours of burnt horizon which is
the start of year four for Rainbow six
siege comes with two new operators and a
new map which is pretty standard but I
think we both really like the operators
this time around in particular you
really liked gridlock yeah so the
attacker is gridlock and she has the F
90 and the m249 saw which is similar to
maestro's light machine gun her
secondary she has a super shorty which I
believe is a new shock and I don't think
any other operators have this shotgun
and it seems pretty useful I got a
couple kills with it I was having fun
with it but I think it's more to blow I
mean like most shotguns it's more to
open up walls particularly floors which
pairing that works really well with her
ability which are track stingers and
basically these are probably some of the
more science fictiony stuff and the six
siege because you throw this thing down
and then a bunch of little spikes come
out of it it's really hard to explain
but it looks like a bunch of hexagonal
spikes come out of it and and they keep
going like you well they don't keep
going but they go for a while you can
basically fill up a room a small room
with this yeah and what it does is that
innit and a defender if a defender tries
to go through that room they'll slow
down it'll make a lot of noise and it'll
do damage it's 5 or 10 damage for like
every second around or something like
that and basically it's meant to stop
roaming is what they said it is it's
it's not a trap they made it very clear
that it is not a trap but it is to stop
roaming roaming yeah I feel like that
will be very interesting as far as
roaming characters go and as far as
creating choke points where you can like
plan around where you're going to attack
and be like well we can kind of block
off this one section so they don't
really have anywhere to like escape from
or anything like that
there was a we were already finding
interesting uses for it
the kitchen in I think it's called
shallot jelly yeah yeah and they there's
that window in the kitchens the end from
this window that people who a siege will
know what we're talking about what if I
just throw
her ability into that window and sure
enough it just like cause complete chaos
where they were just trying to figure
out what to do and it actually even
killed the last person which was great
that was a really fun like victory cam
there it's also easy to get rid of too
it's just loud and you'll probably waste
a lot of ammo because only takes one
bullet to destroy one hexagon but you
have to destroy each one individually
unless you can shoot it right as right
as gridlock throws it down if you see
that then you can shoot it right away
and you can just stop the spread
immediately but another good use we
found out is to throw it down like if
you're playing Bob you plant the bomb
and then throw it down on the bomb
because then they have all these traps
they have to get through to actually
defuse the bomb so either they have to
walk through that or shoot all that and
if they shoot it you know people are
gonna know where they are and it's gonna
be easier to pick them off that way yeah
there seems to be a lot of interesting
uses for that I would like to I think
it's gonna be very map dependent and
then like knowing the map is gonna be a
huge focus for her abilities yeah I
imagine it'll be very useful on the the
airplane I think the presidential plane
yeah I think it'll be very useful on
that and then another important note we
have here too is that it doesn't hurt
the hostage it looks like it just avoids
the hostage so you throw in the hostage
room the the hex exit the spike hexagons
we'll just go around the other new
operator is mozzie and you seem to enjoy
him quite a bit yeah he's got a commando
9 and a p10 roni which he has is really
sick like reload animation that yeah
feels really cool when you use it I like
both of those weapons a lot they both
felt really good
and then they also have the super shorty
as well seems like that's kind of a
through-line for both of these
characters but I was really stoked on
his ability the pest launcher which is
it's funny enough I actually like
thought about this like I feel like a
year ago like man they should do this
which is essentially you can hack the
attackers drones and use them against
them so you have three of these
I guess pests that you can shoot and you
can either hit it directly on a drone
and you'll take it over or you can place
it like on a wall like next to a door
and has this sort of circle circular
radius that if the drone flies into it
they'll instantly get attacked by it I'm
really curious how people are gonna
handle this because in it creates this
whole different dynamic at the beginning
of the match for the defenders where you
have these drones coming in and you're
like oh no no no don't attack these
drones I need to take them but then that
can be weird where it's like well if you
know your ma's he's not on point with
taking them
you could spend it's like well they got
all the information they needed you can
even steal twitch Jones right you can
still switch drones and that's maybe the
most interesting thing about mozzie is
they have a lot of interactivity with
the other operators you can still twitch
drones which is really funny just to
like take that twitch thrown in there
like shoot them back with it I
that's got to be a worse like losing
your twitch drone early on is already
annoying enough but not only losing your
twitch drone but having the defenders
control it must be so infuriating
exactly and you can't get it back once I
take it it's it's mozzies like you can't
get back at all can't hack their feed
though right you can act their feet so
if your toka be you can when you act the
end the enemy's cameras you also do hack
the drones as well so you can see them
so I had a moment where I actually found
one of their drones that they hacked
like looking at me and I was able to
like shoot it
so there are counters for it
I think IQ can also still like detect
them the same way as well so you can
kind of be like oh like they're using a
drone and you know we're not using it so
obviously that's a hacked one it's
interesting where I feel like there
could be a situation with mozzie where
you are maybe not actually getting any
points because I would I would there
would be a match where I technically
didn't earn any points or kills but I
spent the whole time using their drone
to point them out for you guys to attack
and it's like at the beginning people
just don't know how to handle that
because they're not used to the idea of
sparing drones yeah we're like having a
drone like watch them you can watch out
for that so I think there's gonna be a
lot of really unique strategies coming
out of like the past launcher and all
the things you can do with it but then
the map we also got to look at was
pretty cool it's called outback and
originally it looked like a gas station
which it is it's a gas station hotel and
a convenience store all in one building
perfect I don't know how that works in
real life but whatever it's fine and
there's a garage too of course but I
liked it because it seemed a little bit
more intimate than some of the recent
maps they've done yeah it's still like I
don't think we played enough to really
figure out the strategy and the
different areas but I feel like I had a
pretty good handle of where things are
where different landmarks are like
there's a giant shark and then there's a
there's a media room and there's a
there's like a for some reason there's a
bowl what are those called
like a riding bowl okay [ __ ] bowling
ball or whatever in one random room for
some reason but yeah I I did like that
map quite a bit and how its laid out it
definitely emphasizes some tight
quarters and it feels a lot smaller then
right recent maps especially what was it
the one with the one in the last
operation I thought was a little too big
for me mm-hmm yeah I'd agree which I
guess it pairs pretty well with like
like gridlocks abilities
well yeah like a good map to try her out
on yeah I like the map as well I mean
they they like color-coordinated the
different sections as well a little bit
with like signs and walls so you kind of
know like oh this is the hotel part and
this is the convenience store part so it
felt like I was getting a handle on the
map pretty quick and yeah obviously it's
gonna take more time to figure out like
the proper strategies and stuff but it I
think it's a good map yeah it's it seems
like a good a good pair of operators
good map to kick off your for mmm so
yeah that's a look at the new stuff for
year 4 so far I'm pretty happy with this
I feel like these operators are gonna be
much more impactful for me at least I
didn't really use like Nomad and Caillou
at all I got it they didn't end up being
significant to the game for me so I
already can tell that I'm going to care
a lot more about these operators and the
changes they make are going to just
impact the game especially the pest
launcher also big thing for me is I like
both of their weapons a lot usually
that's a big factor for me with an
operator is that I'm just like oh I
don't like their gun
yeah the f9d in particular is really
cool and the m249 saw which gridlock has
has like the best ACOG scope I think so
yeah I think overall we're both pretty
happy with this and I'm definitely
looking forward to playing more yeah
they were both a lot of fun all right
guys thanks for watching and for all
updates on Rainbow six siege stay tuned
to game spot
[Music]